The fastest way to become the person
that you want is to surround yourself
with people who give you no choice but
to become them. And so I think Leila and
I are very proud to announce that we're
bringing in for the first time ever in
our career a partner into our business
at acquisition.com which is the man, the
myth, the legend, the Michael Jordan of
the the real estate industry, Shiron
Servata. I'm so excited to be here. This
is so fun. I'm so excited. I can't
believe it's finally here. Over a year.
over a year that we've been talking
about it now. You remember we're doing
the whiteboard session in Alex's office
and we were like talking about the whole
plan. We plan the whole thing out and
it's like the countdown began. Alex had
a little timer on his phone. Yeah, I
did. And every like for days and weeks I
would just be like 78 days left, 54 days
left until we could finally announce
this. I think that it would be helpful
for everyone to know kind of like the
thought process behind the decision and
kind of our relationship and how it's
evolved to even deciding to do this
because, you know, getting into a
partnership, you know, you've heard our
content before. It's I mean, it's like
getting married. It's a huge it's a huge
decision. I think we were all equally
terrified. Yeah. No, just like not
wanting to anything up. Yeah. And we've
been So, what a lot of people might not
know is that we've been friends for six
or seven years now and like very good
friends. So to give you some context and
and we'll walk through the some of the
timelines cuz I think it'll be relevant.
But like when we were selling the
company, I was talking to Shawn every
morning like, "Hey, what do you think
about this and what do we think of this
deal term?" And even before that, uh,
you know, I had I got introduced to him
from a mutual friend of ours and we had
a a Zoom call at like I don't like four
or five o'clock at night and I don't
really take calls in the afternoon. Was
like, "This is so weird." And I was
like, "I don't know, but this guy seems
awesome." from what this guy had said
cuz he'd already sold a company for $3.4
billion. I was like, I want to talk to
somebody. He was like, it's for sure a
scam. Yeah. Like I was like, who are you
talking to that did that? Yeah. And so
anyways, we hopped on and then we ended
up talking for like three and a half
hours, which never happens. And so I
think that's pretty much how it kicked
off. And we very quickly became very
good friends. Well, I remember what
happened was like Alex went on the Zoom
call, right? And then I made dinner, all
the stuff. He comes back at like 8:30
and then I was like, "How was the call?"
And he was like, "You need to meet this
guy. Like, you'd really like him." And I
was like, "Yeah, most of the time when
he introduced me to someone, I'd be
like, listen, something smells wrong
about this guy, right?" And then I
remember like I was so hesitant, but I
was like, "Okay, he would not like be
like, "You need to meet him if he didn't
think so." He's like, "No, I think like
you would get along really well with
him." And I was like, "Okay." He's only
said that about like two or three people
ever. I've been right every time.
Correct. Do you remember the first call
though? What we did was um Alex was on
the call. Yeah. And we just drew
processes out on a white on a on an
iPad. Yeah, I do remember cuz I remember
being like blown away. I was like, "Oh
my god, how do you know all this stuff?"
And then I was like, "Can I pay you
money? I don't know what to do." And you
were like, "We're just friends." And I
was like, "I understand, but this is
more I just need I need you to help me
with shit." And you were like, "No." And
I was like, "Yes." I was like, "Please
help." And so I would say Shiron was the
original kind of first trusted confidant
for our money. So like we had you know
good amount of money prior to the sale
and then obviously after the sale there
was even more. And so the game of making
money versus the game of making your
money make money are two completely
different games. There is crossover
where one makes you better at the other
and the other makes you better at the
first. But there's still a ton or for me
there was a huge amount of ignorance
that of I mean even around tax law of
like oh wait hold on these I I'm getting
this distribution but I'm getting taxed
on this too. I was like, "But I paid tax
on the money the first time." Yeah. And
then like, "Wait, you can have other
things that can appreciate and then
there's blends for cash flow and and all
of this stuff." And then it's like, "Oh,
there's there's buckets that you can put
your investments into so that you can
optimize towards different outcomes."
And all of this stuff was stuff that we
didn't know. And we ended up creating
our money rules list. I think three four
years ago. You guys might have seen a
video of mine where was like, "These are
the money rules. These are money
algorithms." A lot of those stem from
from Chiron. It's so cool because like
you're you're really great at marketing
and brand. you're really great at
investing and you're really great at
operating. And it's like every time I've
seen one area, it's just like the depth
of knowledge in each area, too. It's
like it's not like you're shallow and
all. It's like you deep knowledge in
each of those areas. I think that's when
we really started talking a lot more
because then it was like, okay, we're
talking about all the cuz we're doing
the same and that was really fun for me.
I remember when when the time between
after the sale after I s we had sold
Telus and I was just doing investing
private equity stuff. I would just talk
to both of you saying, "Man, I don't
know what my next thing is." And the
crazy part is, I think a lot of people
don't know this, but you were the first
people that I talked to about the real
opportunity. And I said, hey, I have
this. This is super interesting. Small
public company, 200 million in revenue,
and you're like, you get to go work.
Yeah. Go do that.
It's funny to like sit back and think
about it all because I think um too, I
was like thinking through before we we
sat down here. I was like, how did this
conversation even start around us all
working together? Because I we I had
obviously talked about with Alex for
years before we'd ever talked about it
with you cuz I was and it was more of
like um I was like, "Oh my god, is there
some way we could bring Chiron on the
board or like bring him in as like like
how do we involve him somewhat in act?"
And it was just like something I didn't
know how to do and it's like normal. I
remember telling him. I would ask Chiron
about this, but I can't ask him about it
because it's him. And then uh I'm trying
to think about do you guys remember how
we started having the conversation about
I I know exactly what happened really.
So, we were at dinner and then I said,
"Man, I I think I've hit all the big
goals." We went from 200 million
valuation to a billion dollar valuation.
And I said, "I'm done. I think I'm just
going to retire." And Alex just laughed.
He's like, "You would be so bored being
retired again. You've already done
this." Yeah. You should just come work
with us. Yeah. And we could do it for a
long time. Yeah. And I was like, "Ah,
you don't want that." I was like, "No, I
do want that. You should totally do
that." And so, I'll give you a little
bit a little a little bit of backtory.
Well, Quinton Tarantino know this. We'll
we'll put the pieces together. But
Shrine came here as an immigrant, as the
only child. His parents sold their
belongings to get him a one-way ticket
so that he could be here. And then
immediately you met a mentor who took
interest in you with your very thick
Indian accent, which you can't hear
anymore because he worked on getting rid
of it. And then what did you get
accepted to a program? What was the how
like what was the gap there that that
got you into like the that that software
company? So, how how it all happened was
for my senior paper in college, I I
wrote this I wrote the senior paper in
computer science and I pitched at a
programming contest at Berkeley and one
of the judges said to me uh after I
pitched saying, "Hey kid, you're not
going to win." I was like, "Thanks a
lot." But that was a good idea. I just
funded a couple of the guys. I think
what you are sharing would be perfect
for them. And that was my first foray
into, you know, having a startup. And
so, I actually lived in my in my aunt's
basement. I had no money and we were
building a startup down Sand Hill Road
raising cash and this was during the
boom. So we we raised 20 plusish million
dollars and then sold that business
overall. So it was all by chance when I
was of my senior paper pitching at a
programming contest. So you got the exit
money from that deal and learned a bunch
of stuff about deal making in that
process which we'll get to another time
and then you took off for like five
years to play professional tennis and so
plays professional. He's like oh great
I'm done. I don't need money anymore.
I'm going to play tennis for the next
five years. Can you imagine Alex
explaining this story to me after he had
you had told I was like, why is what? I
was like, yeah, this guy's a tennis
player and he was Indian and dad. He's a
billionaire. It's it's awesome. Like
what? And so so uh after that though,
you're like, you know, I need to I need
to get back to work. So then you went to
get your NBA. Yep. Yeah. So went to
Vanderbilt. So he's a fellow fellow
commodore. For those of you who don't
know, I also went to Vanderbilt
Community College. Yep. Community
college. Western. Um
that's what they that's what the kids
call it. Um anyways, so goes to goes to
Vanderbilt for the NBA and then goes
from Vanderbilt into Goldman Sachs on
the credit side, right? Yeah. And then
calling all these business owners to you
know talk about financial products and
investing things like that. Did you is
that how you found Telus? Yeah. So one
of my clients was also an investor just
had invested in this in this real estate
company and he said hey I invested in
this real estate company. can you come
and take a look at it and that's how the
Telus process started. Telus was how
many years? Five. So in five years
Shiron went in bought a huge chunk of
the company. We went from 300 million in
gross volume to the 3.4 billion in five
years and then they sold that company
and then that got integrated into
Douglas Element. Douglas Element. Yeah.
And so after that sale, he then was
like, "Okay, I'm going to do another
five or six year stint of of of the the
Chiron. What do I do with my life uh
investment?
I have I have so much money. What do I
do?" Dude, I remember the first time
when we hung out with you during that
stint, too. Like you were like, "You
guys want to go to breakfast?" at like
9:00. Yeah. We were so stressed like
breakfast on a Tuesday at the middle of
my day. So an ongoing joke that you
don't know is that we are like trunk the
only person we do breakfast with only
literally I would I I say no to every by
the way I had no idea. Oh there you go.
I still had no idea until I know I
thought I'd surprise you. It's like we
you eat from like 9 to like 115 and it's
like well there's my entire morning.
Sorry.
We also drank like 14 cups of decaf. So
yeah until it actually starts hitting
you like calf when you drink that much
of it. But we um but anyway, so you you
you did that and that's I mean I I say
that jokingly, but Strillo Capital got
started and then that was really the
family office component of it where you
did private equity and venture side
investments and then a bunch of real
estate stuff as well obviously because
that's the the background that you come
from. You had a huge mix of doing that
and then that's that kind of got us to
the to the real situation where real was
doing you know 200 million or has a had
a $200 million uh market cap and it was
it 36 months? Yeah. Not even. Yeah. So
less than three years went to 1.2
billion. So 6x in less than three years
when Chiron came in. And so that is uh
that is the the Michael Jordan of the
real estate industry. Not not only doing
a billion dollar company once but twice.
So he's 100% on his real estate um
companies getting to a billion. And so
we're just honestly we're I I would just
say like I'm beyond thrilled to have
Chiron in here because it's it was such
it was so natural because all of the
major business decisions and strategic
direction stuff that I would end up
calling Chiron about anyways like I feel
like you I was shadow I was getting you
as a shadow deacto partner and so the
the integration has been almost like we
just get to hang out more than we did
before.
Yeah, it's really interesting because I
also think during that time where you
started and you were doing all the
investments yourself, we kind of took
your structure and mirrored it for us
and that's when we learned about private
equity, when we learned about investing,
we then we found seven real estate
partners and the only one that ever
ended up working out was from you. Well,
I'll say the ones that worked out well.
Yeah. Yeah. Worked out well. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Sorry for anybody out there,
but the only impressive returns and
deals were from you. like now it's like
I can't imagine the fact that we didn't
work together before not the same time
but like around you know yeah very
similar time frame and then that's when
I think we started talking more and more
about we shifted from investing to
business and then as acquisition.com
started taking off and then you had like
I don't know what the next step is then
it was like it just felt like it made so
much sense and I think we were all so
worried like is it like how's it going
to be what and it's funny cuz I remember
the first your first day like when we
sat down in a meeting together it was
Like I was so nervous. I don't know why.
It wasn't even my meeting. I was just
shadowing and and then it was like after
45 minutes and then we're like by the
end of the day it felt like it felt like
this has always been how it has been.
Does that make sense? Yeah. And like now
it's like I can't imagine the fact that
we didn't work together before for all
those years. It's crazy. Well, we kind
of did.
I was just not on the official Slack
channel, but that's fair. Like you've
told me about this. I'm like I know. But
I well I think the my favorite kind of
part of the story is I got to see
gym launch and sale. I got to see the
early idea of acquisition.com.
I got to see Acquisition.com version
one, the building and the growth of
Headquarters, Acquisition.com version
two, and then all the stuff we're
planning for the future. And so it feels
like I've had a chance to see and be a
part of it in from the outside looking
in, but the inside looking in is even
cooler, which is which is the best part.
Yeah, it's it's just it's super fun. I
think for anybody watching too, you
know, as as we're talking about this, I
think a good lesson to take away is like
I think one thing that was really
apparent to me early on at least is like
why did Alex say like, "Oh, you'd like
this guy, right?" He said that because
most of the people that he would, you
know, we we talked to and I'm sure you
have the same thing. It's like they just
want money. It's like they're in
business. I think it's like there's
people who are in business to make money
and then people who are love business
and love making cool and then make money
by consequence. And when I met you, it
was clear that you were the type of
person that you like building you like
being excellent and building a great
business and money comes as a
consequence of that, right? money comes
as a consequence of the fact that you
actually really love people and that
you're a really great person and that
you have values that you value your
family and like there's just so few
people who have that where I think for
me especially like it's so important to
me that anybody that we work with
doesn't just have this one area like
they know how to make money but they
also can build a great business they're
great to their team they're great to
their clients they have a great
reputation they have a great family life
they take care of themselves personally
and it's like when I met you it was so
clear that you had all those you weren't
just like one area and sacrificing all
the Because, you know, I think there's a
difference between like building a great
business and making money. We all know
that. And so, I think that's why also
just like very early on and throughout
the process of being us being friends. I
think the reason it was so easy to be
friends is we have shared values. Well,
I'll tell you this one thing, and I
learned this from both of you, which is
you can't just be good at one thing. And
to win in life, I'm sorry, you have to
win at everything. And sometimes you
have seasons of life where one takes
precedence. Like Alex will say, I have
the season of no. Or you say, I'm
working on my health. That's great. But
you have to win at everything. There is
no other choice. And I I bet people are
thinking, well, how did this, you know,
how did they negotiate? How to do the
financials of the deal? And I want to
tell people, yeah, no, no, it's worth
telling. Yeah. The the depth of the
relationship allowed for the deal terms
to be really easy. And um for for
everyone watching, Alex and Ila said,
"Hey, just write us an email with what
you're thinking." So, I wrote an email
and then they hit reply all, added
counsel, and say, "Please draft this."
That's all it was. That was the whole
negotiation which would have been months
and years for most people arguing over
terms etc. We had none of that. It was a
I've been through a lot of these in in
my life and I will tell you it was the
most gracious the kindest and it nothing
reaffirmed wanting to do this personally
for me when all that y'all did was hit
reply all and say just paper this. It
was literally the same. It was and it
reminded me of like even just like in
any great partnership, right? It's like
you're just everything's been done ahead
of time. So then it makes the hard stuff
easy because you've already worked on
the hard stuff. Yeah. And and that's I
think a good lesson for everybody which
is if you're getting to the point where
stuff's breaking down on a final deal
term means something else was majorly
wrong before and so if you can get all
of that in alignment the the deal points
are very simple.
I want to I I I want to hit on something
because I think it's important. So, I
said it very casually at the beginning,
but Leila and I have never had partner
that we've basically brought into our
kind of like the holding company. I
spend I've spent the last, you know,
five five years from a content
perspective and the last 13 plus from a
reputation perspective building
reputation. And so, bringing someone in
at that level was a serious, you know,
decision. And if you're thinking like,
okay, well, then why why would why would
they do something like that? like
couldn't couldn't you just try and find
uh somebody you could just just hire or
something like that. There comes certain
levels of skill and experience that are
unhirable.
You know what I mean? Like there's the
deal that uh you know Open AI did with
John Ivy, right? like he's he's now just
basically a co-founder status of OpenAI
because he brings such a depth of
experience and a network and a skill set
and and and and that to replicate that
it would be both impractical and likely
I don't want to say impossible but the
the effort to replicate it would detract
from the whole overall. It's like you
would have to have like two companies to
replicate what what Chiron can do. And
so the vision for where we're trying to
go, if anything, is that this has just
expanded what or brought the future
closer of what we have always wanted to
do with acquisition.com
and tried to pay down ignorance desk as
fast as possible with somebody who has I
mean I mean more experienced than anyone
um on on the deal side, on the real
estate side, private equity side like he
has so much there. But then obviously
from a scale perspective in the trenches
building two billion dollar companies
all within fiveyear periods. I mean I'm
I'm very upfront about the the things
that I I will always reinvest in our
ability to do more. This was a serious
call and I mean you think about for me
it's like you're going to associate
someone really heavily with your brand.
It's a it's a huge bet. You know there's
risk but Sean felt very much worth the
risk because I think what we're going to
do together is going to be really big.
You know it's funny as you're saying
that. You know, one thing I realized
through the whole process is not one
time did I have a doubt. Yeah. Like not
one doubt. Like I like never I never
felt bad about it. I never had any like
hesitation. I just worried that I was
going to [__] it up somehow. And I still
to this day I think we both have that
like I'm hinged on that like what am I
going to do to [__] it up? I haven't
heard that word. Every other situation
we've been in it's just us. It's just
us. I sleep fine. Good lord. I know. I
just take it all for both of us. every
deal we've done, every event, like I
always am the one doubting and
hesitating and I like literally never
like it always felt good. Like it felt
really good for me the whole time. I
think part of it too for like people
that are listening is like that's the
logic side of it. I think there's
another side which is like none of us
have to do this. Yeah. And and because
of that I look at it as like what's the
biggest risk to any of us not achieving
our dreams? Ducks acquisition.com like
all of it is that we stop. And why would
we stop? Not because we can't do it, but
because we don't want to do it anymore.
We don't like it. Because we don't like
it. Yeah. So, like I think about it and
I' I told Alex, I was like, I'm getting
to the point where it's like I just want
to do stuff I love with people I love.
And so, it's like you bring in people
and you become partners with people that
you feel like I will have a higher
quality of life within my business and
enjoy myself more if I get to work with
these people. I think that's really
important. And so I I think for anybody
watching too, like that's a that's a
huge piece of it because people come to
me all the time. They're like, "I'm
gonna hire this person or I'm gonna
bring in this partner." And I'm like,
"Do you like having dinner with them?"
And it's like, "No, I don't like having
dinner with them." And I'm like, "Well,
what why are you bringing them in and
giving them half your business?" You
know what I mean? And so I think like
that's a that's a huge point that people
need to to think about and consider when
it comes to that stuff. I would say that
the second piece too is that at some
point in a business like a lot of people
might be watching this and thinking like
maybe I need to find a partner now but I
think you have to consider the size that
you're at and it's at some point you're
not looking to hire people anymore.
Multiple people at similar levels are
looking to partner because at some point
it's like 1 plus 1 equals 11. That's the
way I think about it except it' be like
1 plus 1 plus 1 equals I don't know 331.
Well, can you talk about that though? um
you you made a great video about it, but
um the early discussions for us revolved
around this metaphor of the barrel, and
I think you you broke it down really
well. I'd love for you to maybe share
share the idea of the the ammo, the
resources around it. Yeah, it's at some
point I think we get into this pattern
when when we're bring people into the
business, bring resources in, it's
almost like they're bullets. Like you
need to give them give the resources to
somebody who's capable of building
something from nothing. And at some
point you have to bring in a barrel. And
when you think of a barrel, you think of
somebody like you who can create
something of nothing, who can be as
effective as you at the things that
you're doing. And at that point, it's
like, if I'm going to bring in somebody
has the same skill set as me, then
that's a different type of thing. That's
not you're not going to hire that into
your business, right? And if you did,
maybe you hire somebody in 10 years,
they're at that level, but not, you
know, and and sometimes never. And so at
that point, you have to say like, I need
a barrel, which is something I can give
ammunition to, and they can just go
shoot it, and they can hit the target.
And so I think like you know Alex and I
are each a barrel and Chiron's a barrel.
So now we have you have two new barrels
and we have one new barrel, right? Well,
Alex talked about it when he first
shared it with me. He goes, "Hey, most
founders are single barreled." Yeah. And
they've got to get to a point and maybe
you can articulate this better, which is
like, "All right, now I get to a point
and now I've got to go raise money or
create something to artificially create
a a second opportunity for myself to to
get the barrel bigger." And what a lot
of people don't realize is the first
time I met both of you, the first time I
talked to Alex, I go, "Man, he can just
make something out of nothing." Like he
can make things up. It is amazing Alex's
ability to make things up and just make
things up that can drive brand, create
businesses, etc. And I was like, that's
who's going to make it happen? And so
when then when I chat with Leo I was
like, "Okay, well you got the make thing
up and make thing happen." Yeah. And I
think there's a that's why it's it's
worked really well for both of you,
right? And so Alex can make anything up
and can make anything happen. And that's
a really powerful combination. And so my
my question for you, Alex, is if someone
is thinking about that in their
business, is there is that the
diagnostic or would you think about a
different diagnostic?
So I think there's like there's so
everything comes down to return on time,
right? Like I think if if we boil
everything down for the entrepreneurs
like you only have so much time and you
have to get returns on your time. We try
and get other people who have high
leverage time which is like not only can
I get somebody who can do something but
they're also bringing in 10 years that I
don't have to learn to get that skill to
then do this other thing with the the
rate limiter which is the whole concept
of barrels. is like you can only ship
things so quickly and there's only so
many opportunities that you can pursue
like and I'm a big advocate of focus
aggressive advocate of focus but you
really never overexpand you just
undertalent and I think the vast and
that undertalent is just not enough
barrels right you have 20 great ideas
you've got one life and there's one you
now if you had 20 barrels you could do
all 20 you've got Elon he's got six big
you know crazy opportunity is his
highest leverage is his ability to
attract barrels probably more than
anything else but with I I want to
circle back to She said with me and Ila.
So I got to somewhere in the
neighborhood of between $2 and $3
million a year. I can't remember the
exact financials but between $2 million
a year when Leila and I met. That was
about where I had kind of like capped as
an entrepreneur. And that was for I
chased too many rabbits. I was too
spread thin and I had six different
businesses. I had all these different
things going on. And then when Lea came
in my life, she got me to focus on one
opportunity. And then she was able to
basically make all these things happen
and also at the same time push back and
be like great idea next year. And that
from an order of magnitude perspective
that went from I mean you think about
where we were there two or $3 million a
year as a solo entrepreneur to adding
one other barrel then took us to nine
figures plus right and it's like okay
and that's why it's like okay well
there's two and this is why Le was
saying the you know 1 plus one doesn't
equal two or three it's it can equal you
know 11. it can be a huge increase in in
throughput. And I think that that
having, you know, a third barrel makes
it I mean, we're excited about, you
know, we've been we've been talking for
a year. It's for everybody who's, you
know, curious. It's like it's not like,
hey, Sean's coming in because we're just
going to like keep doing what we're
doing. We have very big plans that we've
been honestly laying since we started
talking a year ago that have been in the
works that you guys will find out about.
I think that's fundamentally what we
solve for is like with the highest
leverage thing is just like not having
to live Chiron's life in order to to do
that. we can just bring Shiron in and
then get the aggregate benefit of all my
life and my experience, your life and
your experiences and then yours
together. And that's where the there the
the the skills stack and compound. So
there's this framework that I like
sharing a lot which is like if you think
about or I believe that the potential of
a business is based on the aggregate
skill set of the people contained within
it. And if you're the person who has
done every job in the business then it
means that literally only one brain has
is the max capacity of the business. And
so if you were to imagine this as like a
little triangle, it's like all of a
sudden if you just add a second brain,
how much higher the peak gets just from
adding two kind of rate limiters or
capacitors in the business. And when you
add a third, the peak goes way higher in
terms of the capacity for the business.
That's where this gets really exciting.
And there's a third kind of alpha for
everyone, which is what are the
opportunities that get unlocked that
none of us could pursue on our own, but
that we could only do an aggregator
together. And I think that's where
that's where we get these more
sophisticated and yet simpler it's more
more complex to execute simpler in con
in concept uh outcomes that everyone can
agree like man if we could just do this
one thing it could change everything
it's like yeah and that's where I'm like
yeah we could change everything and you
guys are like it will take more stuff
but I I think it's really powerful
though for for the person listening and
watching to kind of decode a little bit
of what Alex and Lea just shared is that
we've experienced this and I I Really
one of my favorite things about being an
acquisition.com is this where we could
have a chat about something and then
Leila will say I got it and then that's
it. You don't have to worry because
Leila got it right or we'll be talking
about something and say I got it. The
conversation is over and the more people
that you can that can say I got it is
insanely powerful for an organization.
Do I say I got it? You say I got it very
often and I I I really appreciate that.
Alex never got it. We sometimes have to
text you under the table. This is this
is your time to say I got it right now.
No, no, but but and I actually think you
made a video about this. You said, you
know, how do you get scale? You get
scale when you ensure that the the the
leverage that is transferred gets
transferred without a change in the
performance in some way, right? Which is
insane. And so probably my favorite
three words that someone can ever tell
me is I got it. Because I know that and
if they actually got it, it's super
super powerful. And when you have
someone like that in your organization,
I would support them, get out of their
way, reduce fiction, get them support,
make sure whatever they want is taken
care of. Not that you need a partner per
se, but anybody that is that can that
has that level of competence and that
has that level of care, I would highly
take care of them. And if you're in an
organization right now and you feel like
you want that recognition, say, "Hey,
partner, manager, boss, whatever, I got
it." And then deliver on the I got it.
That is the fastest way to kind of
building that that trust with your with
your team. No, it's really good. You
say, "I got it all the time." And it's
just like if someone says it to me, I'm
just like, I will ask no more questions.
Like as long as I you know, as long as
you got it. As long as there's
qualifiers there. Yeah. As long as I
know they got it. Well, because I also
think that the other thing it does for
the person saying, "I got it," which
what a lot of people don't realize is
when you say, "I got it," there's an
insane belief system and a
responsibility that you put on yourself.
Because the reason I say I got it is I
can't let Ila down. And so I will work
super hard because I put those three
words in front of Ila. And the next time
I say it, and if I did not get it, then
she's going to be like, "What the heck?"
You know? No. So there is a there has to
be a 100% say do ratio and I got it. You
can't you cannot screw anytime. And if
you do, you're like, I'm so sorry. This
is what happened. Let me go fix it.
Right? So the the number of I got it
that can happen in an organization will
move the business so much faster. It's a
really good analogy. Now I'm thinking
about it. I'm like who says I got it the
most? I can think of the top two people
that say it to me the most. I'm like oh
I always appreciate it so much. I'm like
oh yeah I'll throw this in like I think
um bringing a partner on I think you
know this has been awesome you know for
us but trying to explain like right way
to feel wrong way to feel. I think just
from a pattern recognition perspective
might be helpful. one, we've been
working for, you know, not working, but
like we've been talking about this, so
we've laid a lot of, you know,
groundwork for this so that we can hit
the ground running, but Chiron has given
me and especially Ila attention back.
And so it's like, and I don't like using
soft language, but I'll use it here and
then I'll explain it. But like it makes
like Shiron is making everything feel
lighter. And so I see that as okay, I
only have so much time and so much
bandwidth, which is even less than the
time that I have in terms of like mental
acuity. And all of a sudden having
twothirds of the things that I was
formerly working on now just gone and
being done at the same level or arguably
higher because Toron has more experience
with these things. So, we're paying down
ignorance as we're kind of learning the
edge cases of what is the nine figure to
10 figure marketing playbook look like?
What is the nine figure to 10ig sales
playbook look like? What does the nine
figure to 10 figure product playbook
look like? We're trying to pay down this
ignorance set as fast as we can across
all these functions. But it's like,
well, Sean already did this on the
public level, you know, in a public
company and before that in in Telas at a
multi-billion dollar level. It's like,
well, some of these legal infrastructure
pieces, it's like, okay, well, we we can
and we'll learn it or we can just not
have to pay the scar that I know or the
interest that is going to come due later
because we just pay that debt down now.
And I think that that habit of trying
being willing to sacrifice some today to
not get destroyed tomorrow has served us
really well. But from a from a feeling
perspective, which I don't really tap
into very much, it just things feel
lighter. And I think that if if somebody
comes into your organization, obviously
it works at any level, but if someone
comes into the organization and it feels
heavier, it's it's it's not that person
is not helping you. they're not putting
attention back on your plate so that you
can then eat up the problems that you're
uniquely qualified to to solve at the
higher level than you're currently
solving on it.
No, I think that's really valid. I also
think even even in that case like when
you're bringing someone to make it feel
lighter, whatever that may be, I think
like for me it's definitely very mental.
It's also from a work standpoint, but
like the mental like knowing that even
just like talking things through with
you. It's just like I just value that so
much and I'm so grateful for it just to
talk through things that I didn't have
anybody in the organization to talk to
about before. You know what I mean? It's
like of course but we don't even work on
the same things in the company so it's
different which has just been like a a
sigh of relief of like me being like
this is right and you're like that or
like this is amazing right and you're
like that's amazing. I'm like, "Oh,
okay." Like, it's nice validation. And
then also like be able to run things by
you and learn things that I didn't know.
You know, when we told the team that you
were coming on, like the the way that I
brought it up to everyone, I was like,
"Guess who hasn't taken a company to a
billion dollars before? Me." And I was
like, "So, I would like to bring on
somebody who has like," and I think a a
big learning for me was that, you know,
I I was and of course I didn't talk to
you about it because you were very busy
at the time, but like I was so nervous
to tell everybody like so nervous. So,
like I talked to one of my coaches. I
talked to like two of my coaches about
I'm like, "How do I do this in a way
that positions it really well?" And they
were like, "Well, what's the truth about
this?" And I was like, "All these
everything that we just said here,
right?" And they're like, "Well, just
tell the truth." And it was so funny
because I told the whole team and that
was exactly the frame I used which was
just like I haven't done this before.
Shiron has. We've been friends for this
long. We've been talking to him behind
the scenes for this long. Like these are
all the things and not one person had an
adverse response and still has not like
it has gone insanely well. So, what I
will say is that if if you are bringing
in somebody to help, you don't want to
like skimp out on how you bring them in,
how you talk about it with your team, um
even like onboarding, like it was fast
and crazy, but like I built out
everything and then you were like, I
don't need all that. You're like, I will
do some of that, but it, you know, it's
like you just never know, right? It's
like you don't know. We should talk
about Shiao Shiron onboarded because I
think that would be super helpful for
people who are bringing in high level
executives, directors, partners. Do you
want to hit on that? I mean, we can. It
wasn't even as planned because I end up
having to No, but I love what you did. I
mean, so you know, the first thing that
Shiron did, which a lot of So, this is I
I think this is kudos to Shawn because
he has zero ego, which is why he is as
successful as he is. But a lot of, you
know, partners, execs, even directors
depending like leaders will just say
might come into a company and just be
like, "All right, what's my 30 609?" And
there's nothing wrong with that. That's
fine. But Tron just was like, "Okay, I'm
going to meet every single person who
works at acquisition.com from like the
bottom of the ORC chart all the way up."
And he was like, "This gets me so much
rapid contact and I'll have rapport and
and and
he basically onboarded himself within 10
days and talked to you know 100 plus
people in that period of time and was
like he came back and was like I
understand what's going on now which is
better than like you trying to write a
16page document that trying from because
the thing is is it's always going to be
one person's perspective whereas if you
get a hundred different perspectives you
actually get such a such a a
three-dimensional view of the company
rather than 2D.
kind of paper version. I'll also say
that from a speed of growth perspective,
if we think about the speed of a
business can be derived from the speed
of their ability to make decisions,
right? Well, it's like then what what
speeds up uh decision-m ability. So, one
part is data. Uh well, actually data is
going to be the biggest one. But when
you don't have in the absence of data,
you have patterns, right? You have
basically past data that you can
extrapolate in the future. And so to
your point, Leila, it's like we might
say, "Hey, um, based on reasoning, you
know, just on logic and what we know
about the world, we believe this is a
good a good uh good direction or a good
decision." And having someone who has
that pattern that's already recognized
be like, "Yeah, already did that." Like
that's the right call or yes, and add
this piece because this will come up
later. It it has compressed what would
be maybe multiple hour, two hour long
discussions to then being finally like,
"All right, let's just do it." But that
whole process might take two two weeks
or four weeks to make that call which
then can now be done in 30 minutes. But
then tomorrow we have another 30 minute
decision and the day after we have
another 30-minute decision. But each one
of those would have been two to four
weeks, two to four weeks, two to four
weeks. And like that's where you can see
why a company can grow at 10 times the
rate, a 100 times the rate of others
because minutes versus months is a
massive difference when we look at time
scales for growth. And I think that's
one of the other massive unlocks that
that uh I mean I'm excited that you've
already already given us, but you know
even more in the future. You mean just
how we make decisions? Yeah. Yeah. I
think part of that too is like we're so
we're usually like this and I feel like
you have the unique like you've done a
lot of things like by having both the
sets of skills. So like you can flex on
either side and so like you bring a
really like grounding middle ground. I
don't think I ever disagree with you.
No. Well, thank you. But the I think the
interesting part about the onboarding
which people need to know is the
thoughtful like Leila wrote me a like a
16 to 20 page onboarding plan which was
amazing because because that allowed me
to saying all right let me read through
that and the interesting part about that
was not the plan itself was seeing
Leila's thought process on how the world
works. And I thought and I think that
most people will just say, "Okay, cool.
Hey, let's do a press release and bring
this person on board and hey, for the
first uh few months just meet people."
I'm like, "No, you want 90 days of like
ramping up. That's crazy." Yeah. Like
you have the you need to make you need
to make impact today. And so Alex hit
the nail on the head where if there if
the organization is somewhat larger,
especially if there's a hybrid component
to it, you can't wait for rapport. You
need rapport and patterns very quickly.
And so if you if you if you're talking
to people and five of them say this is
what they love about the company, that
reinforces what that is. And if three of
them say this is the same issue, that
reinforces what that is. And you learn
it very quickly and you learn it from
natural patterns. And that also allows
to rapport. So if if you're newer in a
company, I I would suggest focusing on
rapport and patterns. That would be very
very helpful. The second is to be super
impactful, you have to find the most
granular thing that happens in the
business. So for us, it was me going
through every single line item in RPNL.
Yeah. Right. And so I know you know
everything because where the money goes
is where the business invests and once
you know that you know where everything
is is at. So if you're in a in a
marketing organization, you should know
every single metric, every single
channel and that allows you to kind of
figure out that is the pattern in a lot
of ways. So you people think about
learning top down. You want to learn
bottom up because that allows you to
know what the culture of decision-m
happens. That's what's manifested in the
bottom up numbers. And if you do bottom
up, you can get perspective very
quickly. If you do top down, it takes a
lot of time. I think that's what I was
most impressed with is I totally saw the
the bottom up approach there. It's just
like already being able to recall so
many of the details. I was like, "Wow."
Like just so fast.
I don't even have anything insightful to
say. It was just like really it was
really impressive. Well, I think the
pattern for me is that, you know, if we
bring leaders in in general, I mean, I
think we've tended to we talk about this
publicly anyways, but it was just
further reinforcing of the framework
that like a players don't usually need a
long time to immediately start providing
value. And when we hear someone who
might say like, I'm gonna need a quarter
just to like get my bearings, it's like
probably not the guy or the gal, right?
like every single player that I could
name off the top of my head in this
business like immediately I mean within
the first five day you know first work
week was like I got it I can I already
understand this chunk I'm going to start
eating this and I'm going to understand
these but they hit the ground running
and um every time that I've probably
been like you know what we'll give them
a it's like it's never really worked out
long term or it's just been an also ran
it's been like a they're all right like
they somewhat solved the problem and
they're not a screaming hot pain right
now I'll deal with it later but every A
player hits the ground running and you
know this is obviously no exception. I I
I would love both of your perspectives
on this and I because hopefully this is
helpful for folks watching as they're
bringing people on or you're coming onto
an organization is you want to deliver
artifacts as soon as possible and it's
not just oh I had impact you want to
deliver something real tangible artifact
something as soon as possible and when
you start producing people around you
are like wait a minute he showed up he
tried he showed up he wrote a memo he
showed up he made a video he showed up
he set up a process he showed up he
talked to a vendor right and so it's the
email is not the artifact. The artifact
is the artifact. And the more artifacts
that you can ship early on, the more
confidence you get and the more feedback
you get and you you start to realize if
you're coming in new to an organization,
the more artifacts you can ship, the
better. And when you say artifacts, do
you mean like organizational wins?
Correct. Okay. Just through Hey, um we
readed this memo, here's a video, here's
how we're thinking about this. Like
something I always think about it as
what do you have to show for it? Yeah.
Yeah. What have you done this week?
Yeah. which is a great Doge question,
but you you have to ask yourself, what
do you have to show for it? And if you
have nothing to show for it, and you
it's okay you made a decision, but early
on you have to have to have something to
show for that decision. Otherwise, you
don't get cultural buyin on that. No, I
think that's one piece that people
discount a lot, which is like it I I I
explain this to people. I'm like,
listen, I can know what you're doing,
but if the team doesn't see wins from
you, they're not going to like
assimilate you into the organization,
right? They're not going to know why
should I listen to this person because
you're like, oh well, no, ask Leila.
doing all this for eight weeks behind
the scenes. They're like, "Okay,
whatever." All behind the scenes. Don't
be behind the scenes. The two biggest
piece of advice I give to everyone that
asks me, because we have so many new
people, they're like, "What can I do?"
And I'm like, "One, don't tell people
what to do when you're new. Like, don't
go around telling people that something
they do is wrong. Like, that doesn't
make you smart. It doesn't make you
cool. It doesn't that's not why you're
here. Like, just watch. Just watch." I
was like, "The second thing is offer to
help everybody." I'm like, "Just offer."
just like, "Hey, is there anything I can
do to help you? Is there anything I can
do to support you?" Like, if you do
those two things, it's like, and one
thing I've noticed with you is you're
like, "How can I support? How can I
help? Is there anything I can do for
you?" Like constantly asking those
things. And it's like even if someone
doesn't need something, it's like they
feel like, "Oh, they they asked if they
can do something for me and they're
brand new." You know what I mean? And
you always gain rapport from kind of the
servant frame, right? It's like it's not
telling them uh what to do. It's asking
them what you can do. Just a small
pivot. And by doing that though, then
it's like now I've got one reward cycle
with this person and one, especially if
you come in from the position of above,
right? If they know you have the
authority, you flipping be like, "Hey,
how can I help you?" Like I think that's
the authority hijack, right? The the
thing that you could do that ultimately
will gain you real influence rather than
title-based authority um in the
business. The one thing I will offer is
the the thing that made me feel the most
welcome and secure was Leila's document
because it showed me that she cared
enough to spend all that time preparing
for me. And I don't think most I'm just
going to say most onboarding managers do
that where imagine the anxiety of a new
person coming on board anywhere in the
organization. They want to show up. They
want to be successful. they want to do a
good job, you know, uh but it is the
first two to four weeks are actually the
manager's responsibility, not the
person's responsibility. And us putting
in a little bit of effort up front,
showing them that you have saying, "Hey,
this is this is a plan. Here's a here's
the onboarding plan shows that you care
so much about the person coming on board
as opposed to, oh yeah, we'll just
introduce you around and watch your No,
you don't want to do that." And so I
publicly want to thank you. I know how
much effort went into that. But that
allowed me to see your thinking and also
feel your care which we have a bunch of
new leaders coming on board that are
going to work with us directly and that
it you set the bar for me to think about
them coming on that way. uh and almost
to guarantee their success. And so I
want to take I want to my effort needs
to guarantee their success because at
the end of the day, we just want
guaranteed success. And so I want to I
want to do the effort and I and you
showed me how to do that. That was super
cool. Oh, I appreciate that. I um it's
funny you say that because that is when
I I remember when I walked into a new
job and they had a whole document packet
and like basket for me and the way I
felt was like I'd never had a job do
that and they had like two days where
they spent so much time with me. It was
all structured and it I wanted to give
more to them because of what I got
there. And that was when it clicked for
me of like okay when I build an
organization like the first impression
of just like how much effort they're
willing to put in. I didn't need half of
it, right? And I didn't end up using
half of it, but like that they were
willing to made such a difference in
just like feeling welcome because
you're, you know, you're nervous and
stuff. And so I'm glad it was helpful. I
know the document was definitely
overblown and I did it out of complete
anxiety of not wanting. No, I was it was
I it was awesome. Yeah. I was like if
this fails it's my fault for sure but
that is the responsibility that that the
leader should take right that is that is
the responsibility because you spend all
this time hiring going through the
process making the person feel special
come on board and then you're like
welcome
yeah or even the you know I think what a
lot of people don't talk about I I
prepared so much for issues with
bringing like telling people that you
were coming in of like people being like
well Ila I want to work with you on this
or I'm going to like this or like who's
this person what's going on? Like how
are we going to make decisions? Like I
was completely prepared for all of that.
Um because that's what so many people
told me like happens. So I was like even
though we have such a great culture and
organization like I just need to prepare
for it. And I think a lot of people
that's that's actually where I spent
even probably just as much time which
was having the conversations with people
oneonone talking to people. What does it
mean? What does it not mean? What's
changing? What's not changing for
individuals and then for the company?
And I think that alone is where a lot of
people fail is that they don't do the
work when they're bringing in a new
leader or a new partner to position them
well to step into the organization and
be welcome. Because a lot of times they
do a couple things which like one they
they say it's going to be better with
this person. I don't say any
expectations because I'm like it's going
to be different. Good job. Thank you for
not doing that.
I saw the the worst was like three years
ago when a leader would like replace
themselves. They be so much better with
this. I was like, "You can't." And I
knew. I said, "You can't say that
because it's going to at first feel so
different. They're not going to they're
going to think, well, you said it was
going to be better. It's day two. Why is
it not better?" It's like, "Well,
they're new. What do you expect?" It's
like, "Well, you said." And so, that's
the first one is like just don't set any
of those expectations. Just say it's
going to be different. It's going to be
a change. Here's what the change is
going to look like. And I think the the
second piece to it is explaining how it
like the highly impacted individuals,
how is it, what's going to happen and
what's not going to happen, like what
changes and what doesn't change. And I
think that those are also really
important to explain to people because a
lot of people bring in someone like you
and they're like, "Am I getting fired?
Is this still happening? Like what's
changed?" Like there's all sorts of
things that can go through their brain.
So I always just try to come up with
like what are the things that what are
the obstacles I anticipate ahead of time
that I can just overcome before they
even bring them to me. And I think that
in itself paired with what you just said
like if you do those two things like you
address is there's the communication
plan for how you're going to communicate
to the organization and then there's a
plan for when you bring the person in. I
think that is how you set someone up for
success so when they walk in people are
excited for them to be there not scared
or not annoyed or frustrated or worried.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm just excited for ACQ
3.0. AC point that was your idea. Well,
you coined it. Natural progression,
right? It is the natural progression. I
think that's that's really I think
that's a lot of stuff that, you know,
people are going to start seeing us
moving towards and when we allude to the
big moves we make that it comes with
acquisition.com 3.0. Um, but we're just
preparing. We're uh what do you call it?
What do you writing the ships? What's
that term? Digging the well. I don't
know. Digging the well. Yeah. I mean I I
see I see it like as a progression of
like I would say acquis you know 1.0 was
us helping ourselves directly. I would
say 2.0 was us helping ourselves
directly and helping everyone else
indirectly. So it's like if you document
all these things we show what we're
doing that's going to help a lot of
business owners indirectly. We're not
the one actually like setting up you
know like taking calls for them. We're
like but hey here's how we do it and
here's how we do our market. Here's how
we do our sales. here's how we do these
things in the business so we can help
you grow and and hopefully you know hit
your goals and I would say you know
acquisition 3.0 you know, is how can we
help ourselves directly and help you
directly? And so I see that as kind of
the the vectors, which is kind of the
natural progression. But in order to do
that, you know, from the first time we
met until now, the the size of the quote
indirect audience uh went from, you
know, a few thousand to now, you know,
tens of millions uh that have, you know,
directly been in our network versus the
people even in our interested uh
demographic. And so, um, in order to do
it and do it right and maintain our
reputation, which is, you know, what
we've worked such, you know, such a long
time to do, we want to make sure, you
know, I'll try not to be crude, but that
it's awesome and it's being done right.
And that if we can do that, then I think
that we can, you know, get close um to
the kind of impact that I think all
three of us want to have because you
said this earlier, but like it's hard
for people to comprehend. It's like Tron
really doesn't need to do anything and
we really don't need to work at all. We
can just like live off the dividends
from the buildings and the businesses
that we own and like just work out all
day. Contemplated however many years ago
when you were postal we were post like
should we just do family offices like
just just chill invest our well that was
the original that's the original idea. I
know that was the weird and then I was
like but that idea was so like looking
back so so small. Yeah. It was also very
I mean nothing wrong with serving
yourself. I mean, I want to be clear,
like if you want to do that for anybody
who's listening, by by all means do it.
But I think that to have like when I see
the the the best entrepreneurs of all
time, it's like they're they're able to
kind of like flip their selfish interest
inside out so that it just kind of pulls
the world. Um, and I think that that's I
think it's something that all of us have
wanted to do and it just takes more than
one or two people to do it and do it
right. I just think like at the end of
the day, you know, when I think about
what we're building here and like how it
started and such, I think it's because,
you know, at the end of gym launch, for
example, like it we never we didn't, you
know, we got partners and then we we
were out, right? We never brought
partners into the business to to keep
growing the business in a way that
didn't feel completely
exhausting because at some point it's
not this isn't about the work that you
do in the business. It's about the
decisions, the judgment, the leadership,
the experience. And that's, you know,
it's not like we're like, "Oh, Sean's
going to come and just do so much work."
Like, it's like, "I know you are cuz
it's who you are." But it's like the
judgment you bring, the decision-m, the
expertise, like your thinking, your
brain, right? And I think at some point,
especially like when we sold gym launch,
like I was definitely at a point where
like it had just run off the two of us.
And I do think that I was at a point
where I was like I was okay for a minute
like in that brief moment of like
thinking smaller because I was like oh
my god I'm so tired. Like I was just
like I'm tired. Like I've been up since
4 a.m. going to bed at 8:00 p.m. and I'm
a freaking grandma and like it would be
nice to just have something a little
more a little less demanding of me,
right? And it's funny because I look
back and I'm like it was just a skill
deficiency which is like I didn't have
the skill of doing a couple things which
is like building a team that allowed for
me not to feel that way every day and
building a team where I actually the
like being tired at the end of the day
was worth it because I had so much fun
working with them as well as then okay
maybe you shouldn't be the one making
decisions all day. Like if I'm making 35
decisions a day is that really a good
thing to be doing at that point and I
knew it wasn't. Well, I think that goes
to uh Alex's point of being having the
the undertalented, right? Uh and the the
crazy part is how many times have we all
experienced this where we
didn't mean to be a part of you. You
hired one person and that person did so
good. You're like, man,
everything is so much better because
Michael's here. Like that happened,
right? And when that happens, imagine
that over and over and over and over
again. And that's when you get to do so
many powerful things. It's permanent. I
got its which then you have an
organization of I got it. I got it. I
got it. I got it. And then all of a
sudden you create the space to then say,
well, I still got some stuff. Like I can
still go get stuff, but then all those I
got it lets you go get. Um, and I think
that's what allows you to build the
future because so many entrepreneurs
like have this it's their dream is
really just a dream and never meets
reality because they never have the
opportunity to pursue it because they're
still stuck um undertalented in the
business because they're constantly
feeling like they have to play
whack-a-ole because they don't fully
complete the cycle. Like they get a
threequarter solution, but you still
kind of like leave parts of yourself
behind because you know that someone
hasn't fully got it. I think it's
probably my what I feel most proud of
this team is just like we just have such
great individuals, you know, it's like
everyone's so strong and I think I used
to be able to count on one hand how many
strong people I had in an organization
and now it's like I would have to count
on one hand how many weren't and I
wouldn't have any to put on my hand
right now. You know what I mean? Which
is like I remember dreaming of that. And
so I think at that point then you're
just like when we talk about the barrels
um you know I think to a degree it's
like when you have the skills to build
something amazing and excellent you just
realize at some point you just you just
need to hook with other barrels so that
you guys can help you know it's what I
talked about a lot which is like you
want a vision so big for something that
you build that everyone's vision can sit
inside of it. I think right now we see
the vision for acquisition.com 3.0 know
specifically and we all see how our
visions for ourselves, our dreams fit
inside of that vision and that's that's
when the magic happens. And I think it's
and I I'll say this with jumping on the
the piggybacking on the on the talent
piece which is that I think that whether
you like it or not like I I mean I talk
to business owners that every day and
they're like I want to help a million
people lose weight and I'm like well you
have one brickandmortar store that has
100 customers like the gap between their
I think it's not even it's not even a
realistic dream. It's something that
they say that other people say that's
amazing. And so that's why they keep
saying it more so than they actually
want to do it because if they actually
wanted to do it, they would behave
differently. And so they have like their
thing they say and then what they
actually believe is possible. And I
think that when you bring when you get
these other barrels in and you get more
high quality talent, your scope, your
realm of believability expands. And so
it's great to say hey we want to do this
thing but like you know on some level
like what is reasonable or what is
feasible with our existing capacity and
so we still on some level still
extrapolate forward or project forward
based on what we already have. And so
when you bring those other people in all
of a sudden like your ability to see
further you're like oh I I would never
even considered that. But now that we
have John or we have so and so, like,
oh, they can they we could actually
connect these dots in a way that I never
would have originally imagined because I
would have thought I can't do that and I
don't know anyone else who can. But then
when you meet that person, you're like,
oh my god, all these other huge chunky
things now enter the realm of
possibility and that creates all these
new connections that then expands the
realistic vision rather than the someday
that'll never happen vision. It's
totally fair. Um yeah, the um the one
the one quote that Alex uh actually
probably would say it better than me is
this really hit me hard and
I was I I'm born a very driven person
and in my 20s I I really believed that
it was about the destination. In my 30s,
I realized that it was about the
journey. And then finally in my older
40s, I have finally realized that it's
about the company. And it is the people
that that you're with, the people that
you build with, the people that you grow
with, the people that you can see more
and farther with. It's doing it with
great people is what makes you have the
ability to outwork everyone else.
Because if you think about the
destination all the time, you're like,
man, I got that's what the grind is. I
feel like I'm grinding and I feel tired
and resentful. That's what happens
because you don't have the company or
then you go through this period of
growth and everything is painful and
you're like at some point you're like I
don't need to do this anymore, right?
And then but when you have great company
you're like well wait a minute if I
don't know how to do this I can ask for
help. Can someone else do it? I got it.
And then you realize that the the
growing and the joyfulness becomes so
much more multiplied. I the reason
someone asked me this the other day. I
said the reason why I finally believe
that it's about the company is because
of this one thing. It allows me to work
harder because there is no working
smarter. It's like you realize you have
the company so you can work harder and
that's what's super super powerful. I
feel that so hard. Well, the vision also
expands because the timeline you think
on it also expands because if you're
miserable then you want the misery to
end on some level. And so you're like,
well, I can only really think this far
out because I don't want to do this for
longer than this amount of period of
time. So then it creates this rush and
this pressure to get it all done as fast
as possible, which is very like pushing
energy. Like you're like, I have to just
keep driving even though I don't want
to. On the flip side, if you're like,
I'm enjoying the company on this
process, it's like, well, in 20 years,
we can build whatever we want. And so
then it it just it creates a lot more
fun. And you can dream bigger if you
have enough iotits. And with those I got
it, you enjoy those people. Then it's
like, well, what do we want to do? Like,
let's like let's it up. Like, let's have
let's have fun. I think that's why I've
like had zero feeling of rush with
acquisition.com.
It's just like it's like if there's one
thing, it's like do what you love with
people you love. And it's like find
people that like you would want to be
around even if they didn't work in your
company. It's a big one. And like that
has just been such a huge frame shift.
You know what I mean? Um, I do want to
ask you something though. I bet you
people are wondering, especially like
people who follow you, how's your
content going to change? So, so far the
content has always been a very niche
category king type content. And the
crazy part is we've had a chance to
build, you know, a 1.5 million TAM
audience and build a billion dollar
business from it. And Alex, you talk
about this, right? You go niche, you can
actually create a lot of revenue from
it. But I remember being at brunch with
uh both of you and with my son Neil and
the idea of making content about what
you're working on. That is the thing
that I'm truly excited about. I read
this quote uh which was like to write
the book you have to first live the
book. And which is that Oh no, I don't
think this is mine. No, I don't think I
don't think that's mine. No, I don't
think that's like the days of this like
the days of Jim Ran when you don't know.
You just you just kind of give Alex the
credit for it. But if you have to write
the book, you have to live the book. And
and uh what I'm really excited about is
starting to just look at my calendar and
just talk about what we are talking
about. Like what you and I have are
planning on launching is talking about
what we are doing dayto-day. And I think
that is the thing that people are
missing. They don't see that. They see
the a lot of the how-to stuff, which is
cool, but they don't see the what did
you do to help your business grow. So,
I'm looking forward to living the book
and writing the book simultaneously.
Heck yeah. I'm excited, too. And I think
also just like for everyone that follows
you, like, you know, it has been like
niche niche content, but like if you
just take the word real estate out of
any piece of your content, like so many
people come to our events and they're
like, "Oh, I follow Shiron." I'm like,
"Are you in real estate?" They're like,
"Well, no, but he's got good." And I'm
like, "You're smart." Because that's
what happened with Alex is like in the
early days of gym launch, I had I had a
a lawyer stopped me and he's like, "Hey,
I listen to your podcast." I was like,
"The gym secrets podcast?" And they were
like, "Yeah, it all applies." And I was
like, "Well, yeah, but I say gym and
membership rather than contract and
services." And they're like, "Yeah, you
just swap the words like duh." And I was
like, "Huh, well, that's great." But but
I mean Tron like I'll just one of the
things that also made Tron unique for
this situation was that he also had he
understood content. He understood
personal brand which is how do you take
like when you talk talk about unicorns
it's like okay you find somebody who's
you know the Michael Jordan at real
estate which is a massive you know
market but then also has the op side of
running the businesses that capitalize
on those opportunity which is pure
private equity you know like how do we
you know increase enterprise value
within the business and the ops itself
of the people the hiring the recruiting
the marketing sales all of those
components but then there's also the
like oh yeah and one of those companies
was also a public company and so then
there's the public securities public
market which also he happened to have
this experience at Goldman Sachs for
years before that. So he has kind of
like the bottom up approach of like what
it's like on the floor of the of of kind
of like the businesses that deal with
the markets and then also being the
target of of those those products and
services that are sold. So it's like
this 360 view from a business
perspective. But then in terms of okay
that's all amazing but maybe if Shiron
were 80 he wouldn't be able to come into
this you know our current context and
understand the the dynamic nature of how
business is continually you know
changing and evolving especially with
where attention is going and how how to
just how acquisition works in general
right now. And so, you know, Real was
built largely or at least in recent, you
know, on the back of a lot of Chiron's
speak engagements and his personal brand
that brought in a lot of people uh to
the company, right? And so being able to
marry all of these ideas and then
appropriately value each of them so that
we could mix those things into the most
valuable thing for an entire audience
or, you know, consumer base. Um is just
it's like how do you recreate that? It's
like, oh, I just need another person who
had, you know, who's an immigrant who
isn't afraid to work, came here, uh, you
know, was dumpster diving in the
beginning and then also was able to go
to one of the, you know, best schools in
the US and then go to the the best bank
or what is considered the best, you
know, investment bank uh, in the world
and then also do the the private growth
two times to a billion dollar level and
do it uh, publicly. It's just like and
also have the the personal brand and
also be someone that we like really get
along with and share the values. It's
like yeah, let's just wait for the next
Chiron before we before we try and bring
somebody in to to do what we want to do.
And so um it's like you don't find
another Chiron and um if you do get the
opportunity to find another Chiron, call
me and don't don't bring them.
Um but no, we're we're just I we're
we're super pumped. So excited. Yeah.
like just genuinely uh I think
you know not going too much into my own
but like it's just been so fun even
though it's I know it's hard and there's
a lot of it's still been fun. I remember
it was like your fourth day. Um one of
the members of our facilities teams
messaged me and he was like I just want
to say you seem lighter like you just
seem like you're smiling more and you
just seem brighter. Like is this because
Chiron's here now? And I was like oh my
gosh I think it is. I was like, I'm just
excited. It's fun. That's awesome. That
makes me happy. Yeah. I'm excited to
build Acquisition.com 3.0. 3.0. 3.0.